good to see you man welcome to newcastle
you know what what a
wonderful view as well really nice place
[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
right now i'm standing in
newcastle with my good friend ryan
what's happening brother hello sir how
are you doing so ryan you just bought
this house i said just bought you bought
it a while ago you've just renovated it
this is a brr hmo putting up most of his
money
renting out room by room how much profit
we make of this we'll make about grand a
month
a grand a month so we thought on this
video
that we take you through show you about
what's what ryan can talk about exactly
how he's done it what he's done
uh so but firstly why newcastle
newcastle we think there's a lot of
long-term uh
a lot of long-term growth here and uh
we're interested to see what happens to
the local economy over the next five ten
years so we wanted to park ourselves up
here and just
knew that you could get cheap stock yeah
uh but really strong yields
fantastic oh we'll show us around i'm
excited let's go so when you bought this
then
how much work needed to be done and now
it's fully refurbished
what was it like when you got it and how
much work have you done uh so
it was slightly run down it was like an
only couple that had owned it for many
years
yeah yeah we stripped pretty much
everything out did a full reskin
yeah uh and took a few months on the
refurb chronovirus delays
things like that um you're really busy
right you're an artist you're a musician
you've got a lot going on
based in london right yeah yeah this is
newcastle
i did the drive last night dude it's
long it's not
right five hour drive how on earth
do you find builders manage builders
were you when you're so far away i mean
how did you do that um how are you so
busy
i mean no social life is one way of
doing it but i live with all my mates
so i've got the benefit of never being
distracted by going out on the weekend
holidays things like don't do that stuff
because i'm always with my mates
i'm pretty much always socializing so
i'd
where other people would be going out to
a party i'm coming up here doing a
daydream
day trip and coming back and just
maximizing all my time work or a road
trip or a road trip
right let's go so uh all right cool take
me through the rooms then
yeah yeah so you've got double bedroom
in here yeah
and i'm pretty sure this is the room
we've just left for four to
five as well okay that's not bad rent
yeah it's good
we expected 375. yeah so it's 50 quid
more than we expected which is always
better this is rented gone
and how long how long has it been on the
market how long how long have you
advertised these rooms um
started last week we started it properly
yeah nice i mean looking as well
so we're in newcastle and we're really
close to the center but if you go on
spare room
there's quite a lot of demand down here
here we go
if you go on spare room you can see
flatmates in newcastle so
new today 5 50. yeah yeah right new
today
this dude he looks nice 560. for a room
right new today this kid here 400 90
pound a week
day right these are professionals new
today news today in newcastle
looking to rent rooms for like four four
fifty you've just rented this out within
less than a week bank 45
yeah you bought the house for how much
75.
now the thing that freaks me out i live
in beckensfield you've been we've had
dinners and stuff
nice place houses there are worth
millions of pounds if i wanted to rent
out a spare room in my house in
beckensville
i'd get the same ring that's the thing
isn't it the citrus that's a story
true story i'll show you true story
look i'm pretty sure central london is
like 600. yeah
beckonsfield nothing one of the most
expensive parts of the uk
and would you look at that 550 and there
aren't any new ads
so you're probably gonna get okay 500
500 okay 700. but
the rent's the same the demand is less
you'd spend three million buying a house
like this
in beckensfield you bought this for 75
grand
so i mean what's the lesson there
between ratio of
rent and purchase price every i mean
everything's a trade-off so you can get
better yield up in the north
but if you're southern based you're
looking at 10 hour round trips whenever
you need to come to a site visit so yeah
there's a trade-off with everything but
i mean to me monetarily you need to come
to the north if you want good yield
but you've been crazy as well the last
the last year or two yeah
like you've been buying a lot of stuff
we're going to be heading down later to
a commercial to residential pub
conversion
got a lot of stuff going on when did you
decide you're going to go all out in
property like how did that happen
um i mean bro so it started off and i
know we're going to do
like a little sit down later on we can
talk about more stuff but i came across
your videos
and me and my mate from school his
parents are into property and we spoke
about some ideas i was like you know
i've seen this guy he's doing some stuff
he's talking about refinancing the
property
blah blah blah looked into it all uh
read your book
did a load of things that me and you
went for dinner if you remember 18
months ago now
uh and i was just like you know this is
just it this is this is financial
freedom like everyone knows real
estate's the goal
here's a way of doing it and building a
big business out of it
uh and so now we're at seven projects
um three of which are big commercial
deals and dudes
mad respect man all right cool well
let's have a look at the other rooms
show me around
me stuff okay i got another
so did how involved were you as well
just things like what color to paint the
doors
and all of it yeah yeah you were
literally hands-on yeah i should have
been more hands-on if i'm being honest
shouldn't be more hands-on but i was
learning so i was just trying to figure
out you know what's all the little
nuances of managing a project yeah
didn't really know
but i came round at the end it was like
okay there's a lot of snagging a lot of
last bits to do
sticky notes all over the place do this
paint that put this there do that
and that kind of finished off the job
yeah
absolutely this is the biggest double
yeah very big yeah yeah so out of the
room so you've got five rooms
yeah you've had them on about a week how
many of them have been reserved or
so one of them is gone uh yeah one of
them has gone to four to five
the other one i can't remember the
number i'm pretty sure it's four or four
to five
one of the other double rooms uh and
that's been secured on a six month
yeah which hopefully we're going to roll
over and then we're likely to do the
other the other two
when's your next viewing um
i'm pretty sure the guy who wants to
secure it for the next guy
wants to come in later this week right
and then that'll be two left and once
you've got two left it's so much easier
to bring others in
yeah so yeah i love that another thing i
don't know
i don't know who's managing this but
what we like to do with new
properties once we've got all the rooms
available let's do a block viewing
because then what happens when you do a
viewing if there's two or two or three
of the people that are interested
it's almost like the communication no no
like if you come into your house and you
go hustlers
warren's gone one's kind of reserved
there's three more rooms okay which one
do i want
you feel like i'll think about it yeah
like it's not a desirable thing
if there's another three people looking
going oh this is look at the views
then you're like oh here's my deposit
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's almost like
sales yeah yeah it's interesting
block viewings yeah yeah um you create
that like desirability right because
ultimately everything is sales
you know you probably have to sell the
builder on why he should prioritize your
job over at another person's job yeah
yeah
they have to sell the tenant on wanting
to move in
because money doesn't come from property
money comes from people yeah yeah
no actually but now it's good size
really good size sweets as well
i think you've done so well guys for 75
grand yeah
i think you've done so well i'm really
curious to see what the tenants think of
your can i just show them what you do in
the kitchen yeah yeah
so we have a thing right which is when
you've got tenants do you
do do you give them individual cupboards
and say that's your copy that's your
group with that shortcut
or do you have a bit of a free-for-all
and there's always i think ryan's
decided
a new option he's decided to give them
individual covers with a key on
so everyone's got their own key which is
crazy dude and you get a second one down
there look
you get a front one as well dude they're
gonna have so many keys you know what's
gonna happen you're gonna get corner
excuse me i'm really hungry i've got
some crisps in the cupboard but i lost
my kids
or something i do think an eyesight's a
bad idea have you got a key safe
no you should you could get a key set
for spare keys
yeah that's true essentially it costs
like 10 15 pounds and then you can just
put the keys in there i think we'll end
up just not just getting
not using the keys just you have a nice
numbered card
you could you could just say look if you
really badly want a key you can lock you
up why would they want to lock their
cupboard you know what i mean yeah why
would you want to do that
i don't know where i was thinking like
however many months ago do you know what
though
you just got a trial and error stuff you
did it might be the best thing since the
live spreader the tenants might be like
the reason i moved in here was because
of the keys because at my last house
everyone's stealing my phone
but i'm very close i was i'm not gonna
lie that was a little bit off a little
bit in the thinking i didn't want to
like slate the area but we're in a
slightly rougher area in newcastle so
yeah we just sort of thought i think the
builder raised it as an idea and i was
like yeah that sounds like a good idea
you're from the area
you you probably know more than i do but
now it just seems a bit silly didn't it
well we'll see we'll see yeah we just
have to test everything right that's
business
communal area i mean you could have had
that as a bedroom
yeah and then a big communal area well
that's you know i'm saying about the
ensuite
yeah the other way that's what it was
this was a bedroom yeah that was the
communal room the big one yeah and the
ensuite was the other way
but then the builder and the man and the
letting agent went why have we done it
this way i have interest because the old
builder that we had to fire
because they screwed up the job a little
bit um just didn't pick up on this
and these two guys were like why don't
you switch around make this your
communal room yeah and get the big
double room
on the left and then just flip the door
just let's have a look this is a small
little room but i actually really like
it it's nice but i've got a few socials
in here
i also think communal rooms
are the comments i don't know about
newcastle but certainly in the midlands
they're becoming less and less popular
yeah yeah yeah so normally you have a
big communal room
empty space no one sits in it whereas
this
is a small room but if you've got a
communal room
i quite like it i think students like
communal rooms but i think you know
most most adults professional tenants
they just they just don't need that
social so if they've got a desk in a
working area in their room they're not
going to need a big community like the
same yeah i mean i've never gone with
students
people that want to go no never you've
never seen no
is it similar thinking and just okay the
reason is
is because mixing professionals and
students together is the worst thing
ever you can't do it
so you've got to choose and i've just
always chosen professionals other
students
occasionally i've had like a post grad
or someone that's just finished
in their that's a good one here that's
what's good about newcastle loads of
postgrads stick around
they might be or or they might be like
24 years old and they're just doing
they're doing a bit of uni while they're
working yeah that's okay but not
18 year old yeah you know union students
wanting to have parties but that's nice
i like it
and these rooms as well these rooms are
again they've got you've got fire doors
now i can't help i have to i have to
mention it because you brought it up
you mentioned that you had to fire the
original builders yeah
um what happened i mean so
long story short when we started the
process
we did flesh out the builder do you
understand how compliance meeting the
local authority standards things like
that
and yeah yeah yeah no we we know how to
do all that stuff it's only
about two three months in where i came
to do a few more checks i started to
iron out uh things previously i was like
that looks a bit strange a bit weird but
i was learning at the time
so yeah i didn't really know i was
getting consultation from another friend
of mine who's a builder up here
and he started to go now you need to you
need to really clock onto that and then
um
it turns out they had no idea how to
meet compliance then you had to meet
certain compliance things and they did a
fairly good job with some other stuff so
it didn't cost us an arm and a leg
but when it came to doing the final
fixtures of fittings and the
and the kitchen uh last bits in the
kitchen i've got my other builder to
come in who's much more trusted he's
done the public conversion
and he came in fixed it all up that's
great my advice if you're doing it if
you're doing a big hmo
which is gonna be licensed this is
presumably a licensed hmo right
is this an article four part of
newcastle enough no no oh it's just
outside
it's well outside yeah the art before is
the other side yeah which is good
interesting so when this becomes optical
for which it will
what's gonna happen it's gonna push the
value up but if you're doing
a big html like this um because this is
a big when i say big i mean licensed
go on the council website get a list of
all exactly what needs to happen
compliance wise to be
to be um to be able to get a licence and
then when you get the builders give them
that and say look this is the minimum
requirements you know this is the
lighting this is the the fire escape
windows needed
and the kitchen needs to have this much
work work workspace
and then the builders will have
something to work to uh because every
council is different isn't it so if
you're going from london to newcastle
and like you've done in buenos aires
especially when you're just starting out
it can be a bit difficult when you've
got amateur builders yeah yeah
and and we found as well on the bigger
deals you obviously need the architect
yeah fully clear on compliance before he
even starts feasibility
bro yeah there's big on speeds yeah
really good size ensuites
and two things but you need them the
next man yeah i mean it's funny you said
that
yeah as you said five door it just means
that if there's a fire
it won't normally like a paper thin door
yeah there's a fight just
go straight through the door this is
it's safe there's lots of people in the
house you want you want to have that
fire safety in here
although what you'll find is these
will last yeah yes they are
whereas if you've got a lot i'll
actually put fire doors on some of my
single let's just because i just think
you know what
they'll last a long time
and they're safer why not yeah i'm gonna
say
hold on so we've still got two rooms
we've not been there yeah yeah oh it's a
lot of rooms here yeah man
it's packed out of properties yeah so
this room
interesting interesting layout yeah um
you're thinking you're changing the bed
aren't you yeah i think it got to
three-quarters of a single but again
yeah
little issue with the builders and
putting the sockets too close together
minor details but things like that like
should have just gotten a little bit
further apart do you find with hotels
sometimes when they don't have plug
sockets here they only have them the
other side yeah yeah it's like one you
stretch your cable
yeah little things like this but the
experience if
you like your house if you like your
room
you're going to like you're going to
stay longer which is going to mean
you've got less turnaround which is
going to be more rants
see this switch too big yeah it's just
it's massive it is massive i like big on
sweets
if you're doing this different what
would you do and why orientation
of the like i put the shower in the
other corner
yeah and i know they had the slightest
of the soil pipes but to me it's
imperative just to maximize
the space in here because it's really
encroached on the room because if this
just went back just a little bit less
yeah
it'd easily fit a bigger that would be
nice yeah but hey it's a nice room i
actually said to you earlier
this is my favorite room yeah yeah you
like because of the view though i like
the view
it's very light it's very airy beautiful
views
really nice i love newcastle that's the
perfect newcastle bro yeah it's just so
light
and i want to go through the final
figures of you in a minute because i
want to know how um
you know i'm sure everyone's itching to
know what the revaluation came in
how much rent you're going to make um so
this is the smallest room but still
decent size
yeah yeah um ryan will know about me i
can walk into a room i'll tell you
exactly how big it is
yes i just know and also i actually
predicted
the the refurb cast yeah i was pretty
much bang on
you bought it for 75 grand don't worry
i'm gonna guess
that the refurb cost only 45 grand
spot on exactly but tell us
how much did this cost the entire reverb
including all of the furniture
the finals the new kitchen the builders
having to change builders
how much has everything all coming out
with some
fairly hefty bartering and managing
risks and some mistakes
45 grand all in that's not bad so it
could have it could have been an
overblown disaster if we weren't
if we weren't like fortunate in some
ways well many people if if you'd have
just said
i'll just leave it to you build us do
whatever you want i'm in london do you
think
it could have easily been 70 rand yeah
it really could have so 45 grams very
decent price
so you bought it for 75 you spent 45 on
it
so all in that is one twenty twenty one
twenty yeah
okay so this is the this is crunch time
75 000 plus 45
000 because 120 we're not going mad 120
and you've just had it valued now 145.
145
which means the new valuations one four
five thousand so he's
made twenty five thousand pounds in
profit now gonna refinance
at a 75 percent loan to value and pull
out 108
meaning that he's only leaving in about
12 000 pounds
so basically effectively you bought
you've got this house for 12 grand
which you'll get back in a year 100 uh
rent wise
you're getting four uh four two five on
one 450 but let's call it 400 on each
uh times five that's reasonably
conservative
should easily make two grand a month
yeah half of that's going to go on
management bills maintenance whatever
and half of that is going to be profit
so you expect to make about a thousand
pounds a month
yeah mate really good job banging for a
first deal bro like there was a lot of
like things that could have gone wrong
as well but it worked
congratulations so what would you say to
somebody some top tips
wanting to take on because i think i
personally think if you buy a hmo that's
already up and running yeah
it's gonna be much easier yeah but
you're gonna get much less rewards yeah
different
oh geez okay
i'm so interested to see what they say
about the about these i am so
here we go it's nice garbage really nice
i like it yeah i read it re-graveled it
was all overgrown
was it yeah it's quite a transformation
to be fair so just a garden on its own
then how much have you spent on the
garden
500 foot yeah it's four grand from the
first builder
and then my trusted guy i was like how
much is actually gonna cost and he's
like
500 400 quid i was like there you go go
on you doing so well
top three tips anyone watching this sir
don't want to get they want to get they
want to get doing some projects like
this
you want to get getting their hands
dirty on some refurbs top three tips
go i'd say know your compliance for that
to make sure the builder and the
architect know their compliance as well
if you're doing hmos
i'd say don't get too stuck up on
location what do you mean by um
people would spend ages looking for the
exact street and the right and you're
right to put in that kind of due
diligence but like you end up just
getting analysis paralysis and you don't
actually get the place yeah
you've got to just pick a good area at
the end of the day if a lot of people
live in an area it's going to rent you
just need to find out if it's optimal
for you
so you know i would say every house will
rent out
it's just about knowing the what price
it went out at because those people
think oh is this going to rent is it
going to rent and it will um you've
found an area you've just jumped down
yeah yeah
it's the first thing people say to me
they're like oh but what if it doesn't
rent and you spend all that money i'm
like
it's gonna run it's gonna rest it's
gonna rain i think ultimately
you just gotta just just do it yeah and
that's the other and that's another big
one man that's like
if you if you just do it you'll learn so
much through the process
yeah then that's the main thing isn't it
yeah that's great listen guys
do me a big favor if you like the house
if you enjoy these types of videos
smash the like button below you want to
see more videos like this there's a lot
more coming up with ryan so you're going
to see more of ryan's coming up soon
we'll see more videos like this don't
forget to subscribe and you can do that
right above ryan's face
and don't forget to check out more
videos you can see the whole playlist up
here i look forward to seeing you guys
next time
thanks so much peace out
[Music]